to recap this guy wants to start a
trucking business he's looking at the
cost of diesel overpriced trucks
trailers we were talking earlier
privately today about Trucking being a
half business hard annoying lame
frustrating can you explain to people as
a guy that previously ran a trucking
business why it's a half business well
I'm not sure because you know if he
wants one I've got a hell of a deal for
him
uh Trucking is the ultimate half
business
um especially if you're starting on your
own with one truck depending what you
want to do
um you can make good money at it but it
is a [ __ ] ton of work it's long hours
you're usually not home at night
um especially if you're doing uh long
stuff over the road uh I was specialized
heavy Hull um I did the things that most
of the guys want to do it's the the
quote unquote the hero job because
you're moving the stuff that nobody else
is you're the guy that everybody sees
because you're so big and so different
it's it's what they want to do and they
won't naturally know that there's money
in it and every now and then guys will
take we'll say what the rates are and
people on regular freak out they're like
holy crap he's making so much money they
have no idea what the overheads uh is
it's involved uh insurance is ridiculous
uh as a Canadian company running in the
U.S doing the oversized specialized that
I did I had to carry 10 million
liability insurance that's not cheaper
not cheap at all you want to know how
much insurance I got for my business
sure zero
right
yeah so
um equipment now
I may rather talented individual I can
rebuild my own motor I literally rebuilt
my own multi-action trailer took me
three months to take that thing apart
both for bolt sandblasted cut everything
out that was rotten replace it put it
back together uh that's how big of a job
it was that was 12 hours a day for three
months it's a big ass trailer it is you
want to know how much repairs and
maintenance I've done
zero trade you keep going buddy yeah
it's the ultimate half business uh
multiple trucks you've got
um you know drivers and you can't be
sitting in the passenger seat of every
single truck making sure the guy's not a
dumbass
um you can put cameras in there if you
want to you can't stop them from being
stupid
um and if they're away from home and
they decide they're just not going to
get out of bed that day and not deliver
it's on you it's your problem figure it
out deal with it uh they decide to quit
on you and go home and leave your truck
in Houston Texas
you got to call a buddy and I gotta fly
you to Texas and go get a truck and have
him call you when he gets there uh I
found your truck but your trailer's on
here
what do you mean the trailer's not there
uh uh we'll just start making phone
calls where the hell did the trailer go
it's no big deal you know I only do
specialized equipment cradle's only
worth half a million dollars not that
big of a deal right yeah yeah
so you know you want the stress I got a
hell of a deal for you sitting down here
yeah uh I tell you right now for one
truck operation there was no question I
was in the absolute top half of the top
one percent
period I'm very very good at it I know
what I'm doing and I make a lot of money
I do things a lot of people can't do
you want to do it I'll teach you how
because I want nothing more to do with
it it is the ultimate half business
don't walk away run
there you go guys
so like like that's just one example
okay there's there's loads and loads
more I'm sure they're going to come up
tonight it's going to people are going
to ask questions so you know we'll cross
cross that bridge when we get to it I
already see people piling into the
waiting area to come in Bentley thanks a
lot man I appreciate you offering some
clarity is worry about fuel in my line
of business fuel was nothing you know my
fuel bill was usually around 140 000 a
year yeah my pilot car costs a year were
half a million you know permit costs
were well over a quarter of a million um
you know like so depending what you do
you know I took the course last quarter
when I did the enrollment first opened
can you offer guys some feedback based
on your experience in the course
material just so they hear from somebody
else instead of me okay well as somebody
who built the business like and I did I
built it from nothing I bought a truck
when I was 21 years old didn't know what
I was doing and turned it into a
business that
um
with multiple trucks I broke a million
dollars a year with one truck I damn
near broke a million dollars a year
which good luck most guys do 150 000 a
year so
um needless to say I was pretty good at
what I did but
uh you know so I know how to run a
business I know all of that the mindset
shift to the quote unquote elf business
the the different way of thinking
um it was mind-opening to say the least
like you know I know how to run a
business but I know how to do this and
you literally took the blinders off it
showed a whole bunch more now
it's kind of like drinking from a fire
hose so it's it's like okay there's all
these ideas now what's gonna work how do
I take this concept and monetize it how
do I put the two together
um you know these are things I know
um unfortunately my past business it's
not something I can really
teach somebody to do I could but I gotta
hold their hand and I got to be there
right I can't walk them through from a
thousand miles away how to you know how
to tear a d11 apart and load it up and
you know rent temporary Bridges and
bring it into mines and places that
don't have roads that's what I did
you know I can't teach you that over the
phone I've got to be there and do that
with you so this as on the other hand it
makes you think about stuff in a way
that
you just if you aren't exposed to it
you're not going to know it and this
course this is exposure to it yeah this
is like the red pill for
entrepreneurship you know if I can put
this out that way because there's a lot
of stuff that I've that I've talked
about over the years guys that unplug
you on relationships divorce marriage
you know what works what doesn't work
what women respond to what they don't
respond to and everybody's like holy
[ __ ] this stuff actually works rich is
right like like Brian in the private
zooms he's like Rich did it again it's
another cooperism right you know sort of
thing so yeah like yeah everything I've
given you in the course guys is if I'm
being honest I'm very proud of it
because I think it's better and more
useful than the whole getting the girls
thing and keeping the girls and you know
managing women in your life because this
actually does something for you you can
actually make money you can actually get
freedom in your life you know if you
don't want to work on sunny days and sit
on a boat you can do that right you know
what kind of business can you structure
that can do that the only kinds that I
talk about in the course material which
is why I've put it all together for you
so many people are like I want to start
a business this is my business and every
time I talk to somebody it's always
something that drives them nuts and it's
like well why are you doing this if you
don't like it yeah right and at the end
of the day I was very successful with
what I did I didn't work at the end I
didn't work very hard I rarely worked
more than nine months a year
um and I did the things you talked about
you know no it's nice I'm not going to
work I just I'm going to go get on my
motorcycle and go to the mountains let's
forget it but it it still requires a lot
of time and attention and the amount of
effort and work that I put in like you
said if you're going to put the effort
into work in any ways one not put it
into something that's actually going to
be way more profitable and there was a
excuse my language [ __ ] ton of work to
do what I did if I'd had taken that
exact same effort and put it in with
what I know now which is what I'm
currently doing
I'm going to be wildly successful and I
know I am it's you know I haven't got
there yet
um the ideas are are coming together
they're starting to take shape and um
you know uh uh we're gonna start moving
that way so yeah all right Brittany
thanks brother take care man hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out